well i'd have been on the yard with
black um black dudes that run with the
mess and they from mexican gang there's
black guys who are in mexican games oh
yeah i had no idea yeah so that i didn't
know
[__] yeah there's black sounds like
they talk exactly like them look just
like me yeah fool
are there any rappers like that
and they rap like mexican little robs
or black little robs
what if you're just a normal white guy
and you're not racist and you're not
involved in the underbelly of the [__]
you end up in prison where do you end up
i'm asking you
you have to right i can't just be like
i'm just by myself of myself i want to
go to the library eat alone you go run
with the white boy you have like there's
no they're going they're going they
they're going uh there's no are you
saying there's no choice if you go to
prison you have to be involved in some
politics you're going to period
no matter what yeah
yeah you're going to follow you can't
just be like i'm just trying to just
hang out
because when it's riot time
you need to be accounted for when it's
time to go you need to be what if it's
riot time and i just lay on the ground
like that they're going to beat your ass
they're going to blast you out your
boobs asking
so it's better to just go ahead throw a
couple punches get it over because the
consequences afterwards it's going to be
way worse do the gay fools link up is
hell no is that like their own click
we're not on the yard with the gay fools
oh they're they're they're they're in
peace
okay okay okay so the gays are with the
uh child molesters yeah
[__]
[__] you yeah
[__] from san francisco